Abby Lee Miller hospitalized after a  medical emergency ET can confirm the 51  year old Dance Moms star was taken to a  Los Angeles hospital on Tuesday due to  an old back injury paramedics were  reportedly called to the halfway house  she's been staying at in Long Beach a  source tells ET Abby will eventually  need surgery but is now back at the  house I don't know what the future holds  Abby's emergency room visit comes just a  little over a week after she was seen  for the first time since being released  from federal prison where she spent the  last eight and a half months for  bankruptcy fraud  Abby's scheduled to be released May 25th  I'm nervous